[Music]
foreign
okay
what the
excuse me we're gonna play through this
we're gonna play
[Applause]
oh
um
what are you doing
why are you sleeping oh my what no my
God what the
one why are you sleeping like oh what
are you what kind of shadow puppet
are you all right here we
go no that's not a good
[Music]
oh okay if I could get it off okay I'll
take the rap find that no no no no no no
don't you laugh
whoa whoa what the monkey what the
okay whoa wow yeah I know you're
all staring at this house here it's very
lovely knock knock
oh hi hello uh hi hello
oh okay
Snowman
[Music]
oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
oh oh oh oh hey hey whoa whoa stranger
danger stranger danger excuse you excuse
you Excuse excuse you excuse you
that's what I thought oh it's real dark
okay easy there
all right in this game we're gonna play
huh oh okay oh we're big scary screaming
contest huh
what the what oh I can leave okay
good happy okay I'm dead I'm dead that's
a boom that's a kaboomi that's a big
Kaboom no no no no no whoa whoa whoa too
fast no no no no no no I need to get to
a door that I can close oh no oh no no
no snippy please I don't I got two
radios
oh this is not gonna be pretty
little
Lily
okay
sorry who just peed themselves
why why how why
why
oh my God
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
those are some funky parallax
[Music]
what the what the well that
scared the poopy out of me oh is there
something in the
are those sepi steps or those
oh my God
it's dark
you did that to me
how nice it took us
here whatever I'm coming for you
you're behind me
you think you can play these games with
me you cannot is that a spooking chair
it's a spooking chair hi are you
debating sitting in this booking chair
nice took us
oh okay I'm sure that oh he's gone oh
he's just he's just gone
okay
what I
I oh hi
help me
okay all right then wow all right hey
how you doing
okay
something's going
on right so what what the hi cow
man hi
diving
oh this time I'm doing a backflip I
think
what the hell hi okay why
ah
ow ow ow ow ow
is that gas
oh my God okay
I think I gotta stop this game just for
my own sanity but that's funny
grandma
grandma on the kitchen table you know it
baby
oh god I didn't even know I didn't
know I didn't know
why why why what did I do I didn't mean
to do it whatever I did I didn't do it
it wasn't me die
ah much better but somehow
[Music]
whoa I'm on this rock you can wow I
can't see you
oh
no I get some going
oh oh my God no
[Music]
wow
foreign
[Music]
do I still have all my burglarables
hey
uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'll burgle your soul my burger you're
so right out of your body don't ever
think about it don't ever think about it
ah why
yeah that's a problem is it coming from
me wait me oh no wait oh that was
uh that was not a part of the deal uh
time tapping hey
we can give you some time to decide what
you wanted to do I know it's not an easy
decision
hey that was oddly timed yes I'll help
I'm helpful
who's mine oh you
what huh hey
[Music]
couldn't hear you you were Whispering so
I got closer later that night it's
comforting cold air in the room
interrupts your sleep you soon wake up
again
hey
whoa whoa what is that hi
I can't move
no thank you what is happening
oh no thank you he's here who who's
who's here
the lights turned off maybe there's a
circuit breaker oh is that me that's me
that's me oh hey hey hey
oh God no no
oh oh oh
okay oh
well that's a sight for sore eyes if
it's actually like this whole thing is
still with me
oh God
whoa whoa hey okay
oh hey how you doing
hell hello do you need help I
I'm sorry for everything I've ever done
oh hello
okay
do I win
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait what the
what is that bad is that bad that's bad
isn't it
oh yeah he's that bad oh I'm just a
kid hey whoa hey whoa hey what are you
doing what are you gonna do you big oh
uh
boom did I scare you I hope not cause
that's a lot
I don't know what's going on
you sack of tit you big tit sack wow you
France
ah it's gonna be in my bed
just in my bed holy
cockerduck oh oh
wow wow what the this slice some
wonderful
holy where'd you go uh where did
you go
I am fine
I am very fine okay oh
all righty then that's normal oh well am
I working hard or hardly working
[Music]
DiGiorno
delivery oh oh that's not a good
sound now
oh I'm dead uh Daisy oh Daisy oh Daisy
pretty sure that ain't something that's
uh supposed to happen so let's just see
what we can
oh
wait a few years since I've been in a
church so I think it's
I appreciate the compliment but please
don't don't need his food ain't yours
what I'm dead
okay what is that what what is that what
is that what is that what am I looking
at
[Music]
problems oh
oh no oh oh well okay oh hi um you're
not a slug
oh you're not slugs at all
came to party did you eat
yeah
hold on
Estrella
hello oh all right oh that's a lot of
floors that were flying down in this
weird place that I teleported
wait no I'm headed west oh God it is
wrong oh god oh no oh I'm I'm doomed
I'm okay oh
oh no no I'm gonna run stamina
oh no no not like this
no no no oh well
I hope this person isn't infected with
anything because there's Bad News Bears
for me I'm walking barefoot here
oh whoa whoa whoa oh my way wow
I did not think about it I'm gonna eat
the candy canes
oh my God you dick hole oh wait wait
what the hell is wrong with you
I got you so much food dude
oh hey
[Music]
what
what what what what what what what what
wait what it's a beautiful way what
[Applause]
oh this is how what do I do I just I
mean
I hide in here no okay I can't
oh my God
I think this is a good idea I'm opening
them
okay we're good
why why why why why hello I got keys
that's good
hi hey how are you doing hey what is up
I know I'm gonna face steaming I'm
facing the demon
the Demon's gone unless I'm doing some
horribly wrong
what the oh hi good are you kidding
me
the cooking bro
so I don't know
what that means
oh oh grandma oh grandma grandma grandma
what
ho
excuse that more help
oh
hi oh no hey how you doing hey what's up
oh man Watson is that you hey how you
doing hey wait a minute okay there's no
need
I am
oh I'm going towards it I'm going
towards it
oh
I even regret I regretting my spaghetti
hi Alice how are you doing hey give me
give me a big hug hi oh hi okay goodbye
maybe this was a bad idea
this might have been a bad idea all
right hey
hi don't charge it my dry charged at you
yeah give me them spook spook all over
me spook
spook wow
that is an uncomfy family so what's down
here if
[Music]
ah
you yeah I hate you where is the music
coming from I don't know it's your house
why don't you turn off your haunted
music boxes
hello
okay
bruh
[Music]
oh that's not good
what is this nonsense
battery wanna
but wait why is it still
oh
who's screaming
I'm screaming okay
other than that there hasn't really been
anything
tangible spookiness hasn't even
all right so there's been a little bit
of Just spookiness Happening
oh hi oh oh no and you ain't gonna
get me today oh oh okay you
think you could how you think you got
what it takes to go to Toe with me oh
you do okay you think you got what it
takes took a whole toe shoes oh my toes
okay all right ooh blueberries I'll get
some bloobs
have some bloobs oh yeah
oh yeah leave none for the boys
up for the boys
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
hi hey how you doing I got eight so I
just get out right
[Music]
oh God wait what the hell do you know
where you are oh well I mean now that
you mention it
um
all right no
there you go what do you see what do you
see boy
okay
I guess I read these out of order
why why why why whoa whoa
whoa
hey wow wow that's much bigger than I
thought it was gonna be oh my God
oh what do I know about that
do I do anything about it am I just do
it who do I need to shoot
who do I need to give the old boom bang
e to oh God you're dead you're already
dead
scared me way more than it should have
are you in the naughty Corner are you in
timeout what do I do about this hello
I'm a police officer I'm here to rescue
you I think
[Music]
oh
away
foreign
let me think about things before you
just take action like this I
into too many absurdive things I
need I need some time to think about it
until they get over to come to the
playback
I wasn't planning on leaving you
okay
oh
what the is going on here
wow wow wow
whoa whoa what are you oh
well don't mind if I do
[Music]
I don't like a ticking clock
I was flapping my gums I didn't even
realize I was going to wait a minute
what was that what was happening wait I
I am unaware
of the situation here
is there something down there oh my God
please no I don't want it I'm too ah
yeah I'm too handsome to die you can't
kill me
I think you can kill a face that's
beautiful I don't think so
okay
did that do it
you have to stop
God oh God oh hey oh okay
I thought
all right sure yeah that oh God you're
even worse okay
man
no no
great all right cool they look tired
deceitful they look incomplete deceitful
you've got mischievous hands
oh yeah you're oh
my night and I've seen some hentai in my
life and that is not deceitful
all right
okay all right hi hey how you doing
buddy oh hey okay so I can't go the way
I came which means that I just got to go
further down which makes total sense
yeah definitely the murderer wouldn't be
in the subway
I'm assuming he's down here
I assumed correctly oh he can see me oh
that's not good well he can't get me if
he can't catch me through the trees
this might be one of the dumbest things
I've ever seen in my life okay I very
very close better not be a record oh
what's that move in there
oh
oh let's do that
okay
[Music]
wow I'm wiggling this is the end of our
story make it a good one
you're behind me
listen listen what happened I didn't see
it
wait wait wait
lady lady
God what I was
I wasn't that I was safe oh that made my
toes curl look Captain's common
's mad
oh hello aha nope nothing oh scary
okay oh God Jesus Christmas crime and he
craw I think this is just well then what
oh hi Grandma oh Grandpa Grandma
oh
what is happening who is pooping on me
don't flush please don't flush
laughs
I should
oh God oh God God oh God I was nervous
that is a spider on my eyeball
dude I gotta go man I gotta go I'm
crawling on my belly
what is happening
oh wow
oh
press shift to run
better get the gun and save gun yeah
let's Okay I gotta go get the key oh I'm
going for it baby you can't stop me I
know exactly where the key is wow
whoa whoa I didn't mean it I'm
sorry I apologize uh turn around
where did the children go
wait
[Music]
oh big boy
you can't see me
ah okay
screamed a lot louder than I probably
2004 this game is 16 years old
okay
but Jesus ah is that a uh these boobs or
these something else
oh
okay oh oh
all right here we go
[Music]
oh oh God oh God oh my God
whoa hey holy oh wait no you're not
actually supposed to be a thing oh no no
no no no no what do I do
what do I do what do I do what do I do
what do I do what do I do about you what
do I do about you oh my God no no no no
I oh no
what the is that what the is
that okay use a click signs as a chain
is pulled trip door swings shut it's now
totally dark in the room a soft noise
fills this bridge absorber the walls
sounds like nails tapping oh you
suddenly feel hands all over your
rivaling around you're trying to push
them away but they're strong the door
swings back open the room is lit again
there's nothing
you check your pockets you discover a
hand-drawn picture of a dog you like it
okay great thank you for that I really
appreci
time to hammer it Lexi and I I'm doing
I'm doing it aren't I I'm appeasing you
please
oh perfect there there we are all better
all better we're time to relax and watch
TV
like the good boy I am oh oh please
please
I've got a good boy
oh
well
I hope this is my house oh okay
that's a classic scare sound from slendy
man
I remember
slendy man oh I'm very sorry
but uh what am I supposed to do about
that
oh I hope you're blind I hope you're
blind I hope you're blind nice okay
you're not blind you're not blind you're
not blind
okay good great yeah that's good that's
great oh God here too yeah great
I guess I know where all the eyes went
that was not bugs before but okay
oh the burning bush also I don't think I
had a front door on my apartment unless
this is the front door in which case
again I have more questions I should
have thought more oh
oh
that was not cool oh my God
what was that did I just see
what did I just see clip through the
goddamn fridge
what did I just see
oh what what
okay strawberry man
oh
don't go stay
okay all right good great
oh
my God oh my God oh my God
Man donated bye lathers
no thank you no oh I'm dead I'm dead hi
best get on with it
what did I just
what happened
I'll go this way well
[Music]
memes uh you love memes Diary of memes
ah it's like the oh
it's the old ski game
wow
laughs
what the what the bug
beautiful
where did the car go
um
Sam
wow
hey buddy how are you doing oh
oh that's a problem
what what why would I
oh no all right you know I'll who's
there oh okay I didn't have come on I
just uh
there you are grandma
yeah
Grandma how are you doing gravy crap
you're okay I guess I'm in here now I
can't move hot oh no none of that none
of that is necessary
[Laughter]
good job and a half on three quarters
all right tried it and it goes nowhere
so I'm gonna keep going down this
hallway
considering I can't save her I'm just
gonna try to go down okay I'm gonna go
to the grocery store I'm gonna ignore
all the weird shadowy demons
I'm just gonna ignore all the weird
shots
I'm glowing baby
okay
[Music]
oh no thank you I'd like to stay in my
hole
all right am I free am I free to go
[Applause]
okay why
what is everybody doing there
[Applause]
and I say to myself
all right okay send mail do homework
all right not that where's my porn
[Music]
okay so this is um
well that's a problem
[Music]
totally fine
hello
that's fine that's fine
why are you fine
it was fine I died you died why is there
a shadow manage man take care of the
Shadow for certainly okay you're there
you're charging down the hall oh no
thank you
we'll close the door that's be a good
idea
all right anyway I'm curious man I'm I'm
really curious I'm gonna go down farther
peekaboo
freaking Frack of Frack me
[Music]
I'm fine I've gotta find a way out of
here yeah that's what I've been trying
to do buddy
I've really been trying to do that kind
of difficult don't know which way I'm
going freaking hey hey hey hey all right
cool good girl I'm glad I am glad we're
all glad I'm glad you're glad hishimi we
glad
what just happened while I was looking
at it
everything's on fire
oh everything's on fire
oh I'm so scared I'm so scared go away
Dad don't touch me don't touch me
was this Ironhead that's the scariest
Ironhead game I've played yet
I
ungodly confused
oh
[Music]
oh you
this isn't something that I can use to
protect
I don't know what the hell that was you
silent piece of garbage
oh no oh no
yeah you take my scream
no
oh that's a new one okay just gonna
avoid it no
no no
yeah I know this area
I will not be swayed by such cheap jump
scares
oh no please
[Music]
I'm gonna get good but bad for you good
for me oh
oh hey how you doing hey oh you're
jiggly I like that
hello I know he's in the basement
wonder what that was hey how you doing
hey hi oh
hi that's just my butler damn it
Jeeves you scared me how you doing
Butler okay everything you own is thanks
to me
you're right Jeeves
[Music]
very well let's continue here okay
wait a minute I really love this this is
super fun
[Music]
oh who would poop a demon out nappy okay
everything's fine
just me and the bathroom
oh x x marks the spot oh my God
it's a good thing I've got the maddest
hops huh okay
oh what
[Music]
hey okay there's no need
there's there's no need for that hey
what the hell is wrong with you
I need to feed him oh feed him
I thought you said keep him
oh oh
I can't use these oh Lord toilet
that's not how doors work
how
he
owie owie
it's hard to breathe well use your lungs
breathe from the diaphragm suck it up
and keep moving oh in front of me is the
problem
seems to maybe be uh
there might be a uh oh
[Music]
blade
I see it is like p t
scary ball hello
okay well that's you gonna do that again
oh yeah you are gonna do that again
oh my God stop
what do you mean
that was not scary tonight I'll be
sleeping like a baby I always do after
starting a new project
okay what
the is that
[Music]
oh my God
I don't know I'm just gonna go okay okay
all right you know what that was a bad
idea that was one of those bad ideas I
had I thought I had a good idea that was
apparently a bad idea and that's it game
over everybody we are outings
oh
no wait whoa oh
I'm dead
what's
what
who will carry on the channel in my name
subscribers will obviously
oh
[Music]
it's a pole
I just always slammed the door into my
what the hell I didn't see whoa hey
didn't see you
I'm coming for you I hate it
what is it oh this is disturbing
it's nothing
it was just my imagination hello
peekaboo
oh hey
yep okay yeah okay there's the girl from
The Ring he's just walking around the
apartment that's fine am I gonna be
trapped in this room what is the deal
are you there
far well that's problem I don't know
what to do about that she doesn't like
to be looked that long I don't know
oh god oh
close are you are you close
yeah
this is normal this is normal normal
stuff here
very normal okay this could be hold of
folk or I'm being pranked yeah probably
that one yeah let's go way oh no at the
zoo
they'll assumed me something tells me to
close my eyes isn't actually supposed to
fix it oh no thank you I'm gonna close
my eyes oh
whoa well glad that's gone forever
[Music]
oh is that a key bam God what happened
no it's just you
oh no
do not turn around
oh God should I turn around guys leave a
like if I should turn around okay
oh
when the drugs
okay back to the bedroom who's tumbling
in here
oh what is my look what is that thing
that they don't know what it is
you tell me oh the stent from it makes
you rush one day what am I looking at
you get a closer look and notice its
surface is slowly pulsing
oh
yeah I'm okay I'm okay I'm gonna go now
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
I'm gonna oh my God yeah I'm not gonna
stick around for that oh no please not
the ball sack
please
please oh
oh my oh my God oh my God
listen closely
oh my God bad time to crank it
okay
strange
oh yeah that's normal to be here that's
normal
why would hide how do I hide what do you
mean hide what have you been hide
[Music]
whoa
foreign
my Christmas
won't let you out
you're getting closer to me
oh no no no no no
I didn't mean to go in your room I know
you for paid it
help myself I thought there was the
Indulgence of children
I had to put a stop to it somehow that's
the basement oh God no
okay what is the Craftsman
it's sea but oh God hello
you hit me with a hammer
[Music]
why'd you hit me with Hamer
six or seven what do you mean six or
seven
that was your secret was that a secret
was that another secret 42. Tammy
suffers from alcoholism and paranoia
prone to confrontation compatibility
medium a real handful
yeah I learned that myself
oh no what the hell yeah you know uh
yeah shed skin I didn't take that
literally
anybody dancing
okay
oh yeah
oh that's interesting
oh hello
shall come for you I'll come for you in
the night not completely sure
okay
oh my God
good thing bullets work okay uh hoping
he's not like right around this corner
I'm really hoping
he was just right around the corner
what do I do okay event B uh is that
like one of the uh uh this way is it the
vent I don't know is that the vent oh
now you better check the monitor you'd
be able to see all of Susan's thoughts
and memories I thought I was I can't get
out of this oh God
oh my God
well this music sound familiar let's go
and find this music box yeah
yeah okay
yeah all right
you cheap you cheap you
cheat
oh I'm dead now I could live in this
house sounds dope sounds awesome some
cool doctor
really cool doctor
all right
is that you Mr doctor
[Music]
maybe I was supposed to open the cabinet
at the top of the stairs and maybe I was
actually supposed to be able to go
through that or get a key out of that
that's probably what it is oh god oh no
look see I'm throwing a jump scare
ah okay I just wanted to clear the
nerves a little bit another one
cool and I'm running as fast as I can
out of the building
Lexi and hit him with another jump scare
oh no I don't know what down is
[Music]
why that scared me so much
no it was definitely this one huh
well I can't seem to do nothing so
uh oh
[Music]
but now you should have won what those
three buttons
hmm
sure I'm glad that I took a break from
my car crash to come
was that you
listening that better than you
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
no oh that's a fun cat yeah whose cat is
this
it has a cursed face you have a cursed
face just like me
yeah looking though
thank you
[Applause]
I'm being framed but watch your language
that feels like I did good good oh no
it's not good
oh hey who
got what my mouse got inverted
what happened
oh God hi hello my name is Markiplier I
have a podcast called distractible oh
hey hey
please don't
oh God hi
oh hi hello how are you hey stop that
sure okay
yeah I'm just gonna believe that I'm in
a new place yeah absolutely yeah just
give me a key
why you lock
oh I hey oh what is this oh my God
oh my god I've never
I've never been more worried than that
oh
I'll kill anybody that hurt that dog
I'll destroy everything I'm no longer
afraid I'm vengeful I'm angry
what a lovely day
oh again again again
hey well oh that's not the slide you
would you would you would you oh is this
oh this is the uh this is the uh thing
isn't it this is the map is it oh
no please big imposter man
oh don't do it play my GameCube
probably get in trouble for playing it
this late yeah
hi ah look at that smile are you oh
beer the real jingle and the other is
someone else but
oh
[Music]
okay that was fine oh
that's fine that's okay
foreign
[Music]
okay
oh my God
oh hey
okay
wow wow
hey
is that you
hey uh oh God they're gone okay I'm
gonna hide in the locker which I know
what I can do
I know I can do this oh my God
oh hi
who the frick are you
kind of look like red meat but with
chicken bones and shapes
chicken
oh
I'm amazing oh this is one not safe for
us
my channel is gone I don't think your
grandma was exactly nice
my eyes just witnessed hmm interesting
hmm fascinating
interest oh well then
hi Grandma Grandma
oh grandma
oh who is it okay
what the hell happened I'm alive where
is the car uh I don't know if I'm alive
is that a House on Haunted Hill
what the hell is yeah what the hell is
that hey you get out of here I saw
you
uh weren't meant to see all this but I
figure you can guess where this is going
now huh
no need to tell me twice this is why I
spoke
you're welcome now sleep
very peacefully
can you shut off my light too
sure thing
I would love to
Wham wait a minute
I don't have a daughter
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was no one saw coming I need to go
home to Mummy uh
oh wow my God hi why
someone's throwing a tantrum over there
I'm gonna go back here
[Laughter]
oh my God wasn't it down one and then
over this way to the left here I think
yes it's right there oh
[Music]
hi
oh did you just kiss me
oh
that is a concern
oh you and your great
Lenny
[Music]
Leonard yeah right there bud
okay all right you
you squint your eyes at me oh my God oh
my God hi you know I wanted to talk to
you before but for some reason I don't
really want to now
is that your your beard or you're just
happy to see me
it's all one wait is that you uh
well
this is awkward oh my God
man I should try to call the police but
I don't think it'll do any good oh hi
Grandma you got troll who
who we talking about here
who we talked about
Hello whoa whoa oh I didn't know here we
go here we go here we go here we go here
we go here we go here we go here we go
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go oh got too close
what
hello oh
do I go down
hello
[Music]
oh this room is not available in the
demo oh hi
another friend
um
yeah why not okay hey
that's a little bit of an extreme
reaction oh wait I was the monster I
jump scared you ah nope not that way not
that way not that way
not that one yeah
I'm never ever ever going to remember
that oh wait what's in front of there
it's a mannequin huh
oh my God Hi how are you doing blood is
coming from the living room I might just
call the police
oh my God no okay man okay
hi
You Found Me
congratulations
dude I don't like the darkness
uh
[Music]
was there a way to run away from me can
you tell me where episode 3 is
gay here you go
oh
I've been waiting oh my God for so long
oh my God
and that's all there is this is not
funny who's being unfunny now oh hi oh
figure yes one with the building
terrifying energy exudes
oh why do you gotta do that what in the
hell happened here no what was that what
did you just do
don't switch to a camera view like that
okay I'll just stumble back home
hopefully all the cereal didn't get
crushed in my
what if I accidentally shoot my own
daughter which I think is a scenario
that you're putting in front of me I'm
not gonna do anything I am staying from
this inane experiment this is a VHS
VHS cannot do these things
what was that
oh oh hey oh hi how wow hey
why are you dead
is that me please tell me that's not me
oh my God no oh no oh no let me back in
oh no
oh no let me back in
oh my God
light at tunnel usually means I'm dead
or a way out or
squeaky
I'll just be on my way good day to you
I hate
Dawn I'm not looking at you oh
you're not annoy hey come
now
Carl you bastard I'll kill you ha ha
get him
I didn't know if I
[Applause]
hello
someone there
someone jumped you're gonna jump out of
me
hello Hi how are you hello hey lady
you don't say actually I think their
feelings and wants are very apparent
just looking at that smile on that face
I know exactly what their feelings are
and what they want and um I don't think
it's going to be hard to predict
oh no
oh no baby
we're like uh pushing 9.0 on the
liminality meter
so apparently just oh
hey what's going on over here hey oh
okay I don't want well we don't want
anything but we have so you got a deal
this is what it is and we're gonna deal
with it
okay she must have Twisted her leg in
the tree
what the hell did this to her oh my God
what wants Pizza
and his cause for alarm throughout the
entirety of the city
so that they need to blast the emergency
alarms I'm at my car I am literally at
sure
Kitty
hi Kitty
oh hi
what
what oh my God
oh my God hi Kitty how are you dude
this is my cat I should probably feed it
but this isn't the end of the corridor
is it well well well
that's definitely ketchup it's probably
the room that they put their ketchups
inside
I'm super smart bye hello well
looks like I'm trapped here
ah another basement in the bottom of the
Krusty Krab houses
shirt
oh my god well being that you are a liar
maybe you're actually asking me to kill
you
um
oh
okey-dokey wait
[Applause]
thank you for giving Timmy a snack come
to think of it oh my God man I'm I'm
stumped you know I I'm I'm stumped I can
figure out how to get around him oh no I
can't
well God for the ax
oh whoa who's the shadowy nothingness I
took it it's mine
oh
okay all right
[Music]
what did I see I'm in
as far as I know I'm gonna eat that
I can't get out
through side the palate of wood
I'm sorry
uh sorry all right hey how you doing
um oh okay
another backwards day another glorious
Backwards Day
oh God stop that
oh
[Music]
oh hey wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute you don't want to do this hop
Hopman hopping hopping no hopping please
don't happen
no
no hey happy man happy man wow that's
Darkness
um what's what's oh
what oh
you start
hmm
oh
no
[Music]
no no
could that be one of the guests
I bet I bet I bet
oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Music]
I have meat I got one
you were last seeing the day you
disappeared
I sure was
oh I don't deserve this oh I don't just
okay
[Music]
it looks you just get it over with I
thank you and as always I'll see you in
the next one
bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]